gay marriage is not something that is a
social conservative we can actually
support not only even three just said to
get the government out of our lives
personal and business it's not a
contradictory statement hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer freezing TV I'm here on day
two of the RNC convention in Tampa
senator Rick Santorum is going to be
speaking tonight and we're going to try
to find out if Santorum style social
conservatism is still relevant if
America is going to succeed we must stop
the assault on marriage and the family
in America today a lot of the Republican
Party is only fiscally conservative do
you think in uniting the party having
these issues at the forefront of the
platform is problematic the people that
want to relegate the social issues into
the back room back room so to speak it
out of sight they're a very very tiny
minority of the party I would personally
prefer to leave some of the judgmental
moral issues out of the campaign social
issues are very important to us but
first we need to get America working
jobs and there's a lot of issues that
are very important I mean maybe the
social issues aren't as important to me
per se it's it's a tight race between
Romney and Obama right now and wouldn't
having these extra fiscally conservative
people on board be more important than
promoting say the anti-pornography
enforcement that just passed over the
weekend what I will say is that people
will appreciate if you take a stand what
they don't like is when they can't trust
where you're coming from I am more
libertarian minded there's a lot bigger
issues to tackle right now like you know
crumbling dollar and financial debt and
a whole smorgasbord of issues I would
like to see more control given to the
states in order to govern these
decisions so as you welcome the feds
coming in to
take care of medical marijuana card as
well if the statute is on the books to
be enforced I think they need to enforce
it I believe in the need for leaders to
humble themselves and pray and seek
God's wisdom I don't think this can go
on issues it's going to be about jobs
it's going to be about the health care
if it were going to be about social
conservatism Rick Santorum would be our
Canada